role models are very important for the
region especially in the area of
environment because the Middle East is
really suffering from very big
environmental problems especially the
contribution to global climate change
from the region is quite important so we
need role models that are basically
advocating for the environment working
for the conservation of our marine
resources as well as our water resources
pollution is a big problem and the
certification as a result of climate
change is going to cause big drastic
problems for the future so we need to
take responsibility and we need to act
for this and role models are the ones
who can show us how we can act what we
can do in order to protect our
environment